I want to talk a little bit about
California today because it's going to
expose something that's a much more
general principle in life which we've
talked about before and it relates to
really so many different aspects of
politics in society and culture it turns
out we now have detail about the
February jobs numbers so it's April
Friday we'll get the March jobs numbers
but now we got more detail about the
February jobs numbers and it turns out
that 75% of the new jobs added in
February were added in California okay
of all the new jobs on the February jobs
report seventy five percent came from
one out of 50 states the state of
California this is really important for
a few different reasons and one of those
reasons is that the right will often
slam California as this terrible
progressive experiment that's failing
it's gone wrong except for the
conservative parts of California once
you get away from those liberal coastal
cities it's actually a very conservative
state outside of those cities but anyway
they say that it's this horrible
progressive experiment gone wrong and
then the Trump job numbers come out and
they cheer them of course but 75% of
those non-farm jobs that were added in
February were in California not by the
way in the conservative parts of
California but in those supposedly
ultra-left
failing wacky liberal coastal California
cities so let's talk about this on a few
different levels and I think you'll see
where I'm going with this there's a
concept called the Pareto principle okay
or purrito some people say I say Pareto
why who knows now I know that this is a
principle that sometimes people will
misuse to justify bad policy sometimes
people will use the Pareto principle to
justify racism I want a short-circuit
all of that ok I'm not suggesting any
policy here I'm just pointing out that
it's a useful tool to analyze what we're
seeing in terms of the jobs numbers and
beyond the Pareto principle sometimes is
known as the 8020 rule and it says put
very simply in many areas of life 80% of
the effects come from 20% of the causes
it goes back to an Italian economist
named vilfredo pareto
noticed that in Italy at the time that
he was alive 20% of the people owned 80%
of the land in Italy in sales people
will often say 80% of my revenue comes
from just a key 20% of my clients and
then the other 20% of the revenue is
made up of 80% of the clients I've
noticed that like for example with our
affiliate stations that we distribute
the show to 80% of the problems that
they have technical problems questions
complaints whatever 80% of the problems
are coming from 20% or probably even
less than 20% of affiliate stations our
ad sales that we do on the show it might
not be 80/20 at this point since we're
still building it out but I don't think
it's a crazy exaggeration that 20% of
our advertisers are the big advertisers
and we get like 80% or 75 maybe 70% of
our revenue from just that 20% so it's
not that surprising that in the United
States you've got a country of 330
million people California has about 11%
of the population but in February 75 or
74 percent of new jobs were there so as
a general rule it's not shocking that
some parts of the country are
over-represented in new jobs and other
parts of the country are average or even
below average and you end up with this
Pareto distribution now sometimes that
distribution is used to justify
disenfranchising or cutting people out
of society you can use it to justify
racism and sexism and all sorts of stuff
and that's not what I'm doing here I'm
pointing out that all of these
right-wing critiques about California's
falling apart sanctuary cities are a
disaster high taxes people are moving
out homeless people in San Francisco
Gavin Newsom is a disaster Nancy Pelosi
is a trainwreck all of this stuff check
out for example Charlie Kirk's Twitter
account sometimes here's just one
example of the pylon with California
he's a well-funded propagandist he
tweeted this just yesterday Gavin Newsom
just promised to do whatever he can to
have California help El Salvador after
Donald Trump cut off their foreign aid
maybe the governor should focus on doing
what he can to clean up his own mess
high homelessness failing education
typhus outbreaks okay here's the
hypocrisy on the other hand when the
left points out hey you know if you look
at the 2016 election Hillary won by 2.9
million votes the right will say whoa
whoa whoa that's just California Hillary
won California by millions of votes if
you take away California then all of a
sudden she actually didn't do so well
take California out of the new jobs
numbers a state that you claim is
completely failing and all of a sudden
Donald Trump's average - okay job
numbers don't look quite so good like
Donald Trump always says if we had a
popular vote rather than an electoral
vote election everybody would run a
different campaign in the same way if
California wasn't a state the population
would be distributed differently and you
can't really just say if it weren't for
California Hillary would have lost the
popular vote because those thirty
million people or however many live in
California would be living in other
states so that that's the message here
more importantly the Pareto principle as
a mathematical reality it's logical that
an overwhelming amount of the margin in
an election would appear in just a few
places if you look at the electoral
college it's the same thing there are 12
states that are regularly considered
swing states in presidential elections
depending on where you look 12 out of 50
states meaning 24 percent 24 percent of
US states are responsible for almost 100
percent of the decision-making power in
terms of who becomes president of the
United States Pareto principle so the
lessons are number one don't attribute
agency where there isn't necessarily
agency that's how ancient civilizations
early civilizations got religion they'd
see the Sun go up and down and they'd
say see
like someone must be making the Sun go
up and down therefore God the Pareto
principle and Pareto distribution tells
us a lot about how our world works and
whether it's jobs numbers in California
Hillary Clinton's popular vote margin in
2016 don't attribute agency to places
where what we see are sort of
mathematical distributions this is over
their heads I don't think you're gonna
see charlie Kirk anytime soon tweeting
about this but hopefully it's
informative for our audience as well
today's program sponsored in part by
Express VPN unfortunately stealing data
from unsuspecting people using public
Wi-Fi is a really simple way for hackers
to make money I used to leave my
internet connection unencrypted which is
like writing my password on a billboard
for hackers to be able to find and steal
I now use Express VPN to protect myself
expressvpn secures and anonymizes your
internet browsing it encrypts your data
it hides your public IP addresses
expressvpn has very easy to use apps
which run seamlessly in the background
of your computer or tablet or your phone
it takes one click to turn it on and
costs under seven dollars per month
expressvpn is rated the number one VPN
service by TechRadar comes with a 30-day
money-back guarantee you can protect
your online activity immediately and
find out how to get three months free at
expressvpn comm slash Pakman that's
Express VPN comm slash PA KMA n for
three months free with a one-year
package visit expressvpn dot-com slash
Pakman to learn more